be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and today we're going back or at least
we're doing another installment of our
series on Omega Beyond Omega level
characters and we are talking about
Hercules specifically as he appears
during the events of the chaos war which
is by far when he was most powerful it's
also kind of interesting to you because
a lot of you guys have been asking for
me to cover Hercules for a long time I
just never have
Hercules is interesting I always thought
four was more interesting than Hercules
so I always kind of sided with Thor but
during chaos war Hercules was actually
pretty amazing now as we normally do
we're going to start with a discussion
of Hercules origin and his comic book
origin is actually a little confusing as
a version of him actually appeared in
Avengers number 10 who was a minion of
the villain immortus but it was later
explained that that version was actually
an impostor fun fact it's not the first
time Marvel did that one of the biggest
instances where Marvel did that was when
they teased the return of Captain
America right like Captain America Joe
Simon and Jack Kirby they created him
World War two stop being popular and so
comic books became more science fiction
Captain America stopped being popular so
they cancelled him button they actually
brought him back but he who turned out
to be I think was like Acrobat who is a
villain of the Human Torch and it turned
out to be an impostor maybe was a
daredevil villain I don't remember
anyway it was a villain masquerading as
Captain America and then at the end of
the comic they were like do you guys
want to see Captain America come back
and the fan base was like absolutely so
they brought him back in Avengers number
four but regardless and the real
Hercules would actually make his first
appearance in journey into mystery
annual number one in 1965 now Marvel's
version of the character was created by
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby who basically
lifted the characters straight out of
Greek mythology and inserted him into
the Marvel Universe as someone to serve
as a believable opponent to some of the
stronger characters like Thor in the
Incredible Hulk now as far as his powers
go
Hercules possesses the powers that are
common to all Olympian gods so super
strength stamina durability speed
endurance and reflexes Hercules is also
the strongest of all the Olympian gods
and is skilled in multiple forms of
combat now being of divine origin
Hercules is immortal immune to disease
and has an advanced healing factor but
these are just a few of the powers that
Hercules has at his base level what
we're concerned with is what's going to
propel Hercules to become beyond Omega
level this super powered up version that
we saw during the events of chaos war
now before we get into how powerful
Hercules was during that story we need
to lay a little bit of groundwork to
understand exactly what led up to
Hercules getting to this point so as
most of you guys know Marvel Comics has
stories called The Incredible Hulk you
guys know that
right I mean how else would you know
about The Incredible Hulk fun fact he
only ever appeared in The Avengers
stories said no one ever The Incredible
Hulk had his ongoing comic book for a
long long time it had been cancelled and
then redone and then changed and
relaunched and all that kind of good
stuff anyway Greg Pat took over the
incredible The Incredible Hulk story
really with like the the lead up that
went into like Planet Hulk and then you
got world war hulk and then after the
events of world war hulk Bruce Banner
was basically tossed into a prison about
three miles below grab low ground and
just kind of kept there for a little
while
the issue with this is it's hard to have
an incredible whole book that doesn't
have the Incredible Hulk and so we got
to hawk books kind of going on at the
same time not really to hawk books we
got the Red Hulk by Jeff flow which
covered everything that was going on
with well as it turned out to be a
general Thunderbolt Ross but we didn't
know at the time and then you had be
incredible Hercules and incredible
Hercules basically took over the
Incredible Hulk line of stories for a
little while chaos war was a big part of
that now during the Incredible Hercules
by Greg Pak and Fred van lente Hercules
is trying to stop the Greek goddess Hera
from remaking the universe using a
device called a continuum the problem
with this is that he's basically trapped
in an alternate universe that was
created by a device used by his sister
Athena this promise is for an Amadeus
Cho to basically bring try and breed
Hercules back to his own universe and so
Cho quickly realizes that in order to
locate Hercules in the vastness of the
entirety of the universe or at least the
multiverse he would need more than his
own natural intelligence which is
already among the highest in the Marvel
Universe so he sets out to gain
omniscience by becoming a god and so to
do this Amadeus gathers together for
mythical artifacts The Olympian ambrosia
the apples of a dune the book of Thoth
not the book of thought big on thought I
kind of had to make that joke and the
moon cup of some guy Dhanvantari
something like that anyway once the
artifacts are United chose given the
power of a god but soon realizes that
his mortal body is insufficient to
handle such a vast amount of power and
so he basically finds Hercules brings
him back to earth-616 and transfers the
power to him which combined with
Hercules is Olympian mythology turns him
into the god of gods now we see the
extent of the powered up Hercules in the
events of the chaos war itself
now the chaos war started on the arrival
on earth of Amman Summa Kobashi
basically the chaos king who is a living
embodiment of chaos that existed before
the creation of the universe now this is
one of the interesting is about that
because he kind of is but kind of isn't
reason why I say that is because
technically you have
oblivion right like oblivion is
basically the representation of like
things that don't exist right the space
between the multiverse is destruction
and the multiverse is recreation the
chaos King is like a fraction of the
power that oblivion hat right and the
chaos King was crazy overpowered so when
you're looking at that then it kind of
asked the question how powerful would
oblivion really be we covered that he's
actually super powerful it's ridiculous
how Opie he is but mama makes it weird
because they say he's on par with like
eternity and infinity and stuff like
that but then you were charging to be
more powerful than that right because if
he represents the concept the space
between the destruction and rebirth of
things but technically he's immutable
but regardless the chaos King was on a
mission to eliminate all life in the
universe using several pantheon of alien
gods that he had defeated and then
enslaved and so what you end up having
here is basically this multiversal
threat that will go well beyond
omega-level himself right I mean chaos
king is just that powerful now in the
chaos war storyline Hercules leads a
team of Heroes against the chaos king
and his minions racking up a fairly
lengthy list of impressive feats along
the way for what Hercules is powers in
the gods of God form our Hercules is
able to fly teleport and create potent
blasts of energy from his hands and eyes
additionally his already formidable
strength is augmented to just ridiculous
levels even his footsteps are enough to
create shock waves and craters and he
was strong enough to win a physical
confrontation with the entire Council of
godheads a group made of the central
deities of Earth's various pantheon of
gods considering that the members of the
council often referred to as the sky
fathers are gods that include Odin and
similarly powerful deities the fact that
Hercules is able to send them running
for cover is no small feat in another
instance Hercules was able to summon
Galactus and eternity
both cosmic beings of incredible power
against their wills in an attempt to
recruit them in its fight against the
chaos king it's it's kind of insane that
while Hercules was unable to recruit
eternity Galactus did join the cause but
was easily defeated by Hercules father
Zeus who had basically been resurrected
and powered up by the chaos camp okay I
still believe that Zeus not should not
have been able to defeat Galactus but
again he was basically ultra by the
chaos king now immediately after
defeating Galactus however Zeus was
taken out by Hercules with one blow yet
another testament to just how powerful
Hercules was in that form the Hercules
was also able to use his new powers to
grant ability to others as he did when
he bestowed the power of flight to
basically every superhero on
he could also alter his size and grow to
the size of a planet when he finally
went toe-to-toe with the chaos king and
battled him to a stalemate before
defeating him by throwing him into a
machine that sent him into an alternate
universe now after the chaos King was
defeated
Hercules used the rest of the power
within him to pretty much undo all the
destruction caused by the Kaiba by the
chaos king which left him mortal you
know once again because somehow the
story had to end so while Hercules is
certainly a character of formidable
strength under normal circumstances he
was only way beyond omega-level for a
short time but during that brief period
he was one of the strongest entities in
the entirety of the Marvel Universe
it was crazy how powerful he was but
with that being said guys I want to know
what characters you all want to see
featured in future episodes of this
series right so like list them below
listen down below if you enjoyed this
video go ahead and drop a like if you
guys are new here too comments explained
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rod port and I kind
of did that backwards let's try it again
let's rewind that guys if you are new
here to call this explain make sure you
all hit the sub button to become part of
the robb for if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]